leave up the heading and I just want you
to recall yesterday I introduced to you
or I put names on two laws of arithmetic
can someone give me one of the Charlie
that's right and then it's simple simple
terms what did they mean what does it
mean if something if an operation is you
tainted like plus baby yeah so okay good
so if you're adding two doubles together
right five and three it's the same as
three and five okay
so multiple added addition rather is
commutator you change the order and
multiplication is as well so competative
means order could you go in different
ways what is associative made it have to
do with brackets if you would recall yes
yes
the brackets of the okay yes so what
we're looking at is where you don't have
paired of us if you got like a bunch of
numbers like this okay I can group them
I can add brackets in wherever I like I
can do these two first if I want five
plus eleven or alternatively I can do
these two first one give us 15 and I'll
still get the same thing yeah okay so
we're gonna we get that today okay but
for those who simply like this is how
this works right you're adding and
multiplying you can change order or you
can group them however you please okay
now again still staying in the adding a
ball to play world I want to introduce
to you a third law that's really cool
useful powerful one again it's got a bit
of a fancy name so this is the Handy
which is I'm gonna make sure it spells
right the dispute youtube so competative
means that the numbers can commute they
can rearrange swap places associative
beads you can pick a group you can
associate different pairs of numbers
what does the distributive law me yeah
okay so it does kind of have to do with
Jerry sort of it wouldn't have another
staff
yeah has to do with it this is where I
took your water sharing right it's what
you've got an operation and you sort of
what it well distribute it to different
them so here's an example right I will
do a few of these so if we're
distributing say oh okay I want to say
17 times okay now I don't know my 17
times tables all by 12 times they was
particularly well so this is going to be
a bit tricky for me
I suppose I could set this out like 17
times 12 and didn't do the to the did
two etc that would work with all capable
of doing that but I'm going to take
advantage of something which is to say
that 12 is 10 plus 2 12 is 10 plus 2 so
I'm going to rewrite this light zone so
I've introduced I'm sort of like broken
apart this number okay now if you've
done this there's something really
useful here is you're saying 17 of these
and you're also saying 17 of these
that's 17 times it distributes to all
the numbers inside there right so if you
have somebody follow to you now multiply
by 17 is going to multiply by 10 and
also you know multiply it by 2 so that
multiplet multiplication by 17 it just
gets distributed out to everyone in
there now the really where this is
useful why you got chosen 10 and 2 could
have chosen 3 and 9 or 4 and 8 or 5 and
7 why 10 to 2
it's like do you want your tags or else
I can't number one there even but these
special even numbers like I could do I
could have done for an eight which also
even but these are even more special to
them I really like x 10 Y multiplied by
10 is pretty much the easiest small
vacation there is right what you have to
do it well yeah this next line I'm going
to write that distribution of 17 times
this subject I'm gonna write it like
this okay so you can see this one
product multiply two numbers it's kind
of broken apply it's been distributed
into two parts in the 2000 block now
they much easier to deal with so 17
times 10 of course is something you just
add that 0 onto the end 17 times it's
still pretty easy to do right like we
can wait again just like that's why my
10th we're very very good at EE numbers
now that I'm here I can do this this is
to yeah I start off this question by
saying yeah I don't know my 17 times
they would 17 34 51 yay
and then I'm like aha this is too much
too much effort right but here using
this idea of look that multiplication
can distribute all the rest of them we
broke a plug this question into
something really really easy let me give
you another demo
let's do okay now I do know my 9 times
tables but I don't know them that far
and I don't really do my 18 times tables
so we didn't double as much but I can
use the I can take advantage of the
distributive law again to make this
something easy to do
I could write 9 in a different way
they'll be helpful for me so yes it's
yeah okay I can break apart this stuff
I'm right into a 10 and an 8 that would
work
it would be the same idea I can do it
all the way even easier to them yeah
very good so let me help you to see what
exactly red zone by writing night just
like I wrote 10 is starting 12 is head
costume I'm gonna write 9 as 10 take
away 1 you see that that's what that's
what mine is and so therefore I could
distribute the times 18 I can distribute
it to the 10 and I can also distribute
to that one yeah you see you see what
I've done
okay so it's sort of again split apart
and again if you got another color there
this helps you see it distributes once
as it a distributes what it'll
distribute however many things there are
in there you can have three or four or
five terms and it is that x 18 very
generous
you're just distribute stereo the K is a
good time 80 times 10
hundred eighty take away any teeth and
even though that's still you need to
think a little bit you have to be too
hot you can still get your outlets
around ya reasonably quickly okay so
this is the distributive law okay it
tends to our basic we classification
that's where we're mainly going to look
okay